当我的面试官问我业余都会干什么的时候，我就会跟他说我会去玩逆势，然后基本杀，血染，我就会把我所有的业余活动都会说一遍。
我就跟他说我经常要去旅游的，就是我的年假什么之类的一定是要请掉的，就是我会提前跟他说这些。
就是他必须得接受，如果他不能接受的话，他其实在这一轮会把我摔掉，我就会知道就是大家不合适。
但不然的话你就真的在工作当中，然后你要去请假，然后他不同意，他说你为什么要请假，你可能要生病请假他都不同意。
他说生病为什么不能上班，你就很痛苦就指点小的细节上。
所以其实有点像相亲，就是前期不能太，就是为了迎合别人而委屈自己，不然到最后真的去在一起共识的时候就非常难受。
面试其实很像dating约会，就是你们见一遍，然后互相知道对方合不合适。
哈喽大家好，欢迎收听今天的看我72遍，我是小面包。
我是肉欢。
前几天有听众朋友跟我们说，想知道肉欢是怎么样在一毕业就能迅速拿到十几家offer的。
大家可能对这个经验比较好奇，也想看看肉欢有什么独特的拿offer的技巧。
所以我们今天就录一期，肉欢是怎么样能拿到那么多的offer的。
今天主要是跟大家分享五重笑招跟摄招拿offer的一些面试经验，然后也会分享一些坦辛的经验。
我记得你当时是一毕业就拿到15个offer是吗？
对，我当时研究生毕业的时候，手里是拿到15个offer，然后选了一个我最想去的地方。
为什么要拿那么多offer，而不是选几家想去的再去拿呢？
实话说，就是你毕业记的时候，大家都是非常焦虑的。
而且我在延络的时候，其实就有听说过我的学长学姐毕业的时候，手里都会拿七八个offer，有的也会拿十几个offer。
所以我在经历笑招之前，给自己的目标就是我必须要拿到足够多的offer。
然后从这些offer里面去选，我想的是就是工资最高嘛，最适配我的，在去做选择这样会比较的安全。
就在拿到这么多offer之前都会很焦虑。
会不会有一些是你觉得这个公司可去可不去的，但是你还是去找他们面试了，那这样子会不会觉得有点浪费时间啊？
是的，我刚开始笑招的时候，有很多我从来没有听过的公司。
我也没有去看这个公司它到底是什么企业文化呀，然后背景故事啊，创始人故事啊，这些东西我都没有去了解。
我就是海头，就所有的这个时间段再招人的公司的宣讲会我都会去听，然后会把我的简历分发给他们。
刚开始我感觉我投了得有上百家吧。
就其实只要他来我们学校搞宣讲，或者是有一些同学有一些学长发给我们他们的内推，或者是有一些官网的这种的活动。
我全部都会投简历，我根本都不会看到底是什么样的公司。
那这个简历的打赢费花了多少钱？
很贵啊，全是裁大，尤其是那种宣讲会的时候，因为宣讲会同时晚上我们学校会开好几场，就是它是在不同的场次里面开，
所以我就只会去听它的一部分，然后把简历递过去，我就会去下一场。
那个裁大我记得是两块钱啊，还是一块钱一张吧，简历大概就两页嘛，也不会做太多，因为做太多的话，面试完看不完。
如果是现在的话，你还会去这样海投吗？
还是会说找几家自己心仪的精准的去匹配，然后分析这家企业，把简历再做一些优化这样子。
如果是以我现在的状态去设招找工作的话，我肯定不会海投，甚至都不会投简历，我可能只会通过内推的方式，
然后我一定要打听好我的加一是什么样子的风格，我才愿意去投遞这个简历。
但是如果让我回到我校招那个阶段，我肯定还是要海投的，因为海投对我整个的面试技巧和我领场面试的发挥提升非常有用。
所以说经过这种海投以及海量的面试，断练出来了自己硬拼的能力是这样？
对，因为我刚开始去面试的时候，其实我根本不知道面试流程，我不知道我第一轮要面试吗，然后第二轮要面试吗，
甚至面试完跟我问的一些问题，我也并不清楚，就只会看过一些面经嘛，但是你没有使操过，就真正的使操跟你在网上看到的那些东西是不一样的。
现在大家可能会是互联网上的视频面试，那个时候是一定要面对面去面试的。
那种领场面对面跟别人去沟通交流的技巧经验是一定要实战多次才能够续练出来的。
所以我建议大家如果不知道怎么面试，或者是你对面试会有一些恐惧，有一些紧张的话，你就先海投。
就是不要怕浪费时间，你就先海投，去投很多的公司，然后去一层一层的试过来就好了。
那你当时海投的原因是因为想锻炼提高自己，还是说本质上是因为焦虑，想拿到更多over？
我觉得两层原因都有，而且大家经历啸招的话就会知道，啸招提前批的话就是有一些大厂，
比如说像阿里，然后什么自己，这种的大的互联网公司，我给你去招那种下令营的东西。
正式的啸招开始是在10月份，10月份最开始的这一波前面的都会是很小的小厂。
所以这些公司其实是不太出名的，你就可以用这些小厂做练手。
到10月份这个时候，基本上就是大厂会轮回，集中都会在这个时间里面。
所以你刚好就已经练过了半个月的时间，在11月份初，你就可以去拿到这样刚刚成熟的经验，
或者是很热乎的经验，然后去面对你很心意的公司。
那你在短期内是怎么样做到同时去搞这么多家公司的？
就像你说的，比如说宣讲会，就第一个简历就走，第一个简历就走。
但是这些像面试，或者说像线下去硬拼，它是怎么样压缩到这么短的时间内去疯狂的去的呢？
我觉得你如果想要拿到足够多的offer，就只能去压缩你的时间，尽量的安排好这些面试的流程。
你就只能靠辛苦，其实没有别的技巧，你必须要在这么短的时间里面去面调你所有喜欢的公司。
因为错过了秋招，你就只能上穿招，然后穿招基本上都是有点像就跟高考一样，
就是已经没有招满了这一部分又会去重新补人，但是这个时候的竞争就会更加激烈，
所以大家基本上都会在秋招的时候定下自己的offer。
我在笑招，就秋招了那不到半年的时间里面，我差不多瘦了八井。
就我当时是一天最多的时候我跑四个学校，然后去参加三场比试，差不多五场到六场的面试。
面完了之后晚上我还会去参加宣讲会，宣讲会的话其实就是也是要走流程嘛，
可能要去参加个三四场，一天基本上都不会吃饭。
会带面包直接在出租车上面去啃面包，或者是在烤场外，然后看到卖什么的就吃什么，就是垫一口。
因为基本上你所有的时间都在做比试，然后再看那种你要面试的这个公司的资料，
就是你也得知道这个公司的企业文化，因为对于笑招生来说会有一个必问题，
就是他会问你为什么选择我们，然后这个就是要去讲企业文化跟你个人性格的匹配度嘛，
所以你就要提前去看这些资料。
那在同期你的其他同学也是这样的强度去面试的吗？
其实我已经没有怎么关注的同期其他同学了，因为你所有的时间都会聚焦在自己，
你自己一天时间是完全排满的，但是我发现就是在面试场不是有后场吗，
在那个后场外你碰到的这些其他学校的同学发现大家都是差不多的强度，
因为大家都会很焦虑，我感觉那个时候大家的就业压力是挺大的，
因为我当时还，我的学校其实是个普通的985，
我当时在第一场面试的后场的时候我还碰到过牛津大学的，
剑桥大学的清北副教的这种的严重声，发现我们投的是同一个公司，
我当时就会想啊，现在这个就业市场已经这么卷了嘛，
就是这家公司其实也没有很好啊，感觉大家的压力还是挺大的，
所以其实大家都是在比较焦虑，比较高压的情况下在做这种面试准备。
在这些环节里你自己觉得自己最擅长的是哪一部分啊？
其实我想说一下，我不是成功率高，我是真海投，就是我投的多，
我应该是相对于我其他的这些同学投的都要更多，就是更努力的这种，
不是说我当时确实有面试天赋或者我的共同表达能力有多好，
就也是练出来的，就确实是投的减力非常的多，
然后最后就能从这么多的公司里面筛到了15高分，
因为有一些同学他可能面到了他觉得还不错的公司会停止面试，
但是我是那种我拿到了还不错的offer，新资也不错，
或者是跟我，是有跟我其他的同班同学比，新资也是在一个正常水平上的时候我还是会去拿别的offer，
就是会有一种心理是我能不能再拿到更好的，
因为你会觉得错过了这半年的秋招，那我就再没有机会拿了，
我就丢失了这个硬接生的身份，所以我就会不停的去面试，不停的拿offer，
自对比他们给出的条件。
我比较好奇效招一般是怎么样去面试，或者说怎么样去比试的呢，
因为我自己的印象我不太记得了，我感觉我比试我不知道做了啥，
就像做了个卷子一样交上去了，然后面试也非常的走过场，
我不知道是我面的比较特殊还是怎么样，
所以我看你既然投了这么多，应该是比较有经验或者说比较有感触的，
想听你分享一下。
是的，我经历过非常多，
好玩的面试。
好玩?
对，就是在我参与这些效招面试之前，我根本不知道大家是这样面试的，
因为咱们理解中的面试就是一微一码，然后他问你问题，你回答问题，
我参加过非常多的游戏面试，比如说比较简单的其实就是第一轮要去做那种无准备的演讲，
就是他会临时给你一个主题，让你三分钟考虑时间，然后立刻上去演讲，
讲五分钟，我也面试过那种创业游戏，有点像游戏游戏，
就是当时我们是一个大的，有点像那种阶梯教室，然后里面有几百个人，
你可能投的是HR，可能投的是运营，可能投的是设计，可能投的是销售，
他不管你投的是什么岗位，所有人都会在这个房间里面，
所有人临时组队，我们当时应该是临时组成五个人吧，
组成五个人之后开始想一个创业项目，
我想到这个创业项目之后，就让我们上街去拉路人，
拉路人给到我们评分，然后再回来去做汇报演讲，
我们当时应该是有200多个人吧，然后就要当场淘汰一半，
就真的很像游戏游戏，除了这种，然后我还绑过那种有点类似于老人沙的这种，
就是他会让你玩桌游，这个桌游是他们自己设计的规则，
我有点忘记是具体是什么了，但是他会通过你在桌游桌里面的表现，
就是你因为大家会自由组成小组，然后在这个小组里面，
就会有人自觉变成那个领导，有人会变成什么样的角色，
他就通过你的各种各种表现，然后去判断你是不是能进到下一轮的面试，
比较普通的就是无领导小组讨论了，
参与了这么多就是很奇怪的面试形式之后，
我觉得无领导小组讨论形式太固定了，
就是太好提前准备了，无领导小组讨论就是他会已经提前帮你们分好组，
进去之后你们就会互相介绍互相认识，
然后他会给到你们一个题目，这个题目有点像辩论赛，
就是你们要拿到这个题目自己去想论点，
每一个小组旁边会占一个面试官，
他就会看你们在这里面怎么样去想这个论点的，谁贡献了多少，
最后你选出来这个领导是谁，
这个领导又会上去发言细作PK，
我记得是一个房地产，他的第一轮的面试是玩密室讨拖，
就是进去玩一个20-30分钟的密室讨拖，
然后面试官在后面的监控里面看大家的表现，
是恐怖类型的密室还是说解迷类型的密室，
解迷的密室，因为我当时有看到其他的同学说他去参加了这个面试，
我当时觉得非常好玩，因为我非常喜欢玩密室，
这个场景主要是面试官不在你旁边，
然后他是在后面的监控室里看，
我会觉得压力没有那么大，
你觉得就是哪一类人或者什么样的表现会让面试官更选择你，
一是你的临场反应能力要很好，
就能扛压，我觉得能做这样的面试，
他的目的肯定是压力性面试，
就是给你一个你完全不熟悉的环境，
然后给你一个你完全不知道的场景，
又给你一个你完全不知道的题目，
临时让你去做发挥，
所以这个时候你的扛压能力是非常重要的，
就是在强压力下，
然后能够最快的速度去理清你的思路，
去把你想要表达的东西表达出来，
第二还是要去看你的共同表达能力，
因为这个共同表达能力是，
一是你要展现给面试官的，
二是你要跟你的同气的这些，
面试的同学们要去做共同表达，
因为你们会变成一个自觉分组，
就是你自行分组，
你就要去把这个团队的关系给搞好，
所以你的共同表达，
然后以及团队协作这两个也是很重要的，
第三个的话，
我觉得是逻辑思维能力吧，
就是对于硬件上来说，
其实大家都是临经验，
就是他不会看你到底是有什么样的能力，
或者是看你到底之前有什么样的经验，
或者是不是被这个岗位，
他其实就是看你的逻辑框架是什么样子的，
但是你的逻辑框架大家也大多都差不多，
你只要是能够说出一二三，
就是你要有一套自己的逻辑，
这样的话基本上面试官，
就这一层上面都不会太扣分。
所以我理解为，
扛压能力就是看你在从学校进入到社会之后，
能不能担下那些工作上的事，
沟通表达能力就是跟其他部门协作，
或者说跟领导汇报的时候，
你能不能清楚的把事情说清楚，
逻辑能力就是你能不能在进入到公司的时候，
有比较快的学习能力，
其实它是这样子的设计和原理是吗？
或者是你在进入到公司之后有没有思考，
因为如果你逻辑框架没有答案，
然后他问你一个问题，
你只能给出一条回答的话，
说明你是没有思考的，
就其实他也不管你思考的这个方向对不对，
但是你只要是有一个框架，
可以按照这个框架去说一二三，
就是多想几层，
就多给你老板几个选择，
他们就会觉得你是有框架的，
你是有逻辑思考能力的。
你大学学的是不是HR专业来着？
对，我的本科学的是人力资源专业，
所以我在我大学的实习，
包括研究生的实习，
因为我研究生是心理学嘛，
这两个的实习我本身的方向都是在做一场，
就是我一直以为我毕业之后就是会去做招聘，
我当时理想的方向是，
我想去做雇主品牌，
雇主品牌其实就是做笑招，
因为我想回学校嘛，
就是回学校，
然后再去给大家去做选奖，
然后再去做招品，
因为我觉得就是跟学生打交道，
会比较有意思，
然后会比较新奇，
可惜只做了一年，
但是我的实习经验都是在做HR的。
那你本身做HR去接触到这些面试的时候，
自己内心是怎么想的？
有没有觉得这个好像正撞在我的枪口上了？
我就大概知道它的背后是要干什么，
所以有一些提前要准备的东西，
或者说可以发挥出来的优点。
我自己做了HR，
我感觉就是从HR的这个视角上，
感受最大的一个东西是，
当你面试的时候，
你一定要非常清楚对方做这件事情，
或者是对你问出的这个问题，
背后想表达的目的是什么？
因为我们经常会问面试观很多问题，
甚至是有一些陷阱性的问题，
或者是有一些纯康，
就是压力性的面试，
我们并不是想知道具体的答案是什么，
因为没有标准性答案，
但是我们想问的这个东西，
一定是想要知道你跟公司是不是配的，
因为你的家一，
就是你的老板，
他不是一个标准型的人，
他是有自己的领导风格的，
他有自己的管理风格，
所以我们都是会按照管理风格，
或者是企业文化，
然后去问到一些问题。
你的回答，
可能你的性格不是配于这个公司，
然后大家也是不太能进入到下一轮，
并不是说你表现得好不好，
或者是你的能力强不强，
只是合不合适的问题。
你能给我举两个，
比如说陷阱型的问题和压力型的问题吗？
我还蛮好奇的，
因为我自己的面试经验非常少。
我举一个吧，
就是可能我会去问那个应聘者，
就是你平时的业余活动是什么，
有的应聘者他很外向，
然后他就可能出去玩，
或者怎么样，
然后有的应聘者他就是会说，
他会在家里，
或者怎么样，
这都是比较表象的，
也有的应聘者会迎合HR码，
然后他就会说他，
平时就会去学习一些工作技能，
然后这些工作技能又完全适配于岗位JD，
就其实我们想问的这个问题，
一定是想问你的性格是什么样子的，
因为不同的部门的团队，
他们整体的这些同学，
或者是这个老板，
他的风格是不一样的，
因为有的老板就是很外向，
他可能会对于团队里面的同学，
我不要求你按时到，
或者我不要求你按时走，
就是要固定的时间来，
然后固定的时间走，
他觉得你拿出结果就好了，
所以也希望你有更多的业余的时间，
然后去干其他的事情，
或者是觉得你的性格比较外向的时候，
会更适合去做一些个人打交道的事情，
那比如说去做BD，
比如说去做拉星，
但是有一些岗位，
或者是你需要的这个同学，
他需要你去做中台，
去做一些团队协作的东西，
或者是需要你去做一些数据处理的东西，
那他可能希望你的业余的活动，
就会稍微像内球一点，
他其实是一个性格体，
做其实是看你的加一，
他自己的性格，
或者是他想招的这个人的性格，
或者是他在这个团队当中，
缺的这个人的性格是什么样子的，
他背后要问的这个目的是这样子，
那压力型的呢？
我觉得压力型，
大家应该经常有遇到吧，
就是说，
如果是问的比较直接简约的话，
他就会问说，
你能不能接受加帮，
就是如果说，
我们现在有一个什么样的项目，
他会给你举一个，
场景型的例子有一个项目，
遇到了什么样的问题，
然后你因为这样的问题，
给公司造成什么样的损失，
在这样的一个场景设定下，
你会怎么做，
或者是会问你说，
你没有做过一些不成功的项目，
就是举一些你之前做过的项目，
然后不成功，
你是怎么解决他的，
就是他会给你设定一个，
你没有做好的项目场景，
去看你的解决问题的能力。
有没有一种性格，
身边时官一定会选择的那种，
比较标准的模板型的，
适配于所有企业的性格？
如果是你在HR这一关的话，
大家一定会选择的就是，
你不露出你性格了，
就我刚刚说的那种回答，
比如说我灭了这个岗位是设计，
然后你告诉你的业余生活，
就是去学习这些设计相关的技能，
其实我看不出你到底是一个，
什么样性格的人，
你是在往这个JD上面去碰，
但是你在跟业务面试的时候，
就是你的加一面试的时候，
他一定会再往下探一个层，
就是了解到你的性格是什么，
而且我不建议大家在这个导体上面去模糊，
就是我觉得面试是一个互相筛选的过程，
就你如果这道题上面去模糊，
去迎合面试官的喜好的话，
你在真正转正，
或者是真正工作的过程里面会很痛苦，
就是你碰到了不适配的老板，
因为我完全会通过这一题去筛选我的老板，
就是当我的面试官问我业余都会干什么的时候，
我就会跟他说，
我会去玩密室啊，
然后去本山啊，渲染啊，
我就会把我所有的业余活动都会说一遍，
我就跟他说，
我经常要去旅游的，
就是我的年假什么之类的，
一定是要请掉的，
就是我会提前跟他说这些，
就是他必须得接受，
如果他不能接受的话，
他其实在这一轮会把我筛掉，
我就会知道，就是大家不合适，
但不然的话，
你就真的在工作当中，
然后你要去请假，
然后他不同意，
他说你为什么要请假，
你可能要生病请假，
他都不同意，
他说生病为什么不能上班，
你就很痛苦，
就指点小的细节上，
我觉得那这样很好，
就是不是一种低姿态的，
我一定要迎合你去拿到这份工作，
而是一个双向的筛选，
就是我展露出真实的我自己，
对吧，你能接受，
那我们就一起去合作，去共试，
不行的话那就拜拜，
所以其实有点像相亲，
就是前期不能太，
就是为了迎合别人，
而委屈自己，
不然到最后真的去，
在一起共试的时候，
就非常难受。
是的,
我觉得面试最最重要的，
就是要互相尊重，
然后摆正大家的姿态，
就虽然说，
现在就业市场非常的不好，
但是我们面试，
其实只是刚开始，
就是你进去还要转正，
进去还要一直在这边拿迹效，
就其实是一个非常长线的过程，
所以面试是在这个过程里面，
最快速能够筛选出来合适和不合适的，
不然你后面会非常痛苦，
因为你后面可能会经历，
你转正不通过，
然后你也浪费了很长的时间，
或者是你最后在这边工作了一年，
然后拿了一个不好的迹效，
也没有拿到你预期的工资，
你花费了很多的时间成本在找，
但在这样的情况下，
你明明可以筛选掉它，
然后去选择另一个比较合适的岗位，
或者是另一个比较合适的老板，
所以大家一定是面试，
就是雇主跟我们面试者，
我们双方都是平等尊重的，
就是大家不需要把自己的姿态摆得很低，
说我一定要拿到这份工作，
或怎么样，
其实不需要的。
如果我本人就是那家工作，
我特别喜欢，
我感觉我非他不去，
他提什么要无礼的要求，
我都能答应，
有没有一个通用的模板，
通用的性格，
或者说通用的展现给HR，
展现给领导看的性格模板，
让我们更快的被选择。
首先在面试的过程中，
能够更大几率的进入到这一家的话，
我们先是要知道这个岗位的JD是什么，
就是你一定要去非常详细的研究他的JD，
就是他提出的这个岗位要求，
以及工作技能，
其实都已经给你答案了，
你去看他的岗位JD的工作要求，
是可以抽离出来他需要什么样的人才的，
包括他需要的这些工作技能，
也能抽离出来他需要什么性格的人，
他这个工作技能，
工作要求上一定会加他需要什么性格的人，
尤其是字节的那个工作岗位JD，
他后面会写，
我要工作外向，
工作皮屎，
就性格外向，
或者是能够做从零到一事情的人，
就是他会上面会写，
他有什么样的性格，
所以这个时候你低一点就会知道，
这个岗位需要的有什么性格，
你在性格体上面就是会留意，
你要往什么样的方向去回答，
这就可以往外延展说，
你平时喜欢的活动又是什么，
包括他，
现在有很多秘书会问你的NBTI，
就是你的老板你的LD会，
去看跟他适不适配，
就是你可以从里面去抽离出来，
他需要的是P型的人才，
是J型的人才，
他需要的是T人，
还需要的是F人，
其实都是可以抽离出来的，
你可以通过这个，
就是先模拟一个完美人数给自己，
另外的话，
工作岗位的要求，
每一条后面其实都会导向，
你平时要做什么，
所以你在写简历的时候，
其实你写的你之前的每一份的工作，
你都要跟这个岗位队的起来，
就是你可能之前没有做过相关的工作，
但是你一定会有一些，
可以延展的小的方向，
业务上可以队的起来，
如果业务上队不起来，
你就可以抽离出来，
你的业务的背后的工作能力，
哪一些可以队的起来，
然后你就要在你的简历，
就是你的每份工作经历上面，
去把这个东西非常清晰的写出来，
面试最最重要的就是自我介绍，
大家一定非常害怕，
就是说我在面试的时候，
他问我这个问题，
我答不上来怎么办，
有一个非常好的办法就是说，
你引导他问你问题，
你不要让他自己想问题，
因为我做ESR的时候，
我也不知道问我这个面试关系什么问题，
实话说我在刚开始面试的时候，
我也很愁，我压力也很大，
因为我不可能问，
所有人都是通用问题，
那根本没有面试的意义，
所以我要根据不同的人，
去问他的问题，
但是我刚开始面试的时候，
我也很紧张，
我不知道问你什么问题，
尤其是当你自我介绍，
说了20秒，
就介绍完了你都过去，
然后你完全无从下问，
所以就是让尽量让ESR对你好奇，
是这样吗？
你要给ESR设置好奇点，
所以你的自我介绍非常的重要，
你的自我介绍，
因为他会看你之前的工作经历，
你的工作经历，
你能过这个简历关，
一定是你之前的工作经历，
跟你现在的，
只有工作岗位需要的人，
才是有匹配的地方的，
所以你的自我介绍的时候，
就一定要往这上面靠，
或者是你可以引导他，
因为我们面试的时候，
有很多问题，
比如说你为什么觉得你适配这个岗位，
为什么你能胜任这个岗位，
为什么你比其他人更适合这个岗位，
肯定会问这样的问题，
或者是说，
那你觉得你在面对什么什么问题的时候，
你会怎么做，
你举出你的什么优点，
举出你的缺点，
你不用等他问，
你就在你的自我介绍里面，
把这些全部都讲出来，
包括自我介绍，
你讲的这些东西，
一定是要有数据的，
有事实，支撑，
对，先讲目的，
就是我为什么做这件事情，
再讲我具体做了什么事情，
我具体做这件事，
我又在里面担任的是什么角色，
最后我拿到了一个什么样的结果，
这个结果是非常重要的，
你的这个结果呈现的角度，
就决定了面试官对你怎么样看，
就比如说，
你如果真的在之前的工作里面，
你能拿到一个非常好的结果，
那你就如实写，
就是我在团队拿到了第一名，
我在团队拿到了375，
我在团队拿到了1，
面试官一定会问，
你为什么能拿到1，
别人拿不到，
他一定会对你这个好奇，
但是如果你只是拿到了一个普通技巧，
然后你是一个之前团队里面，
可能平平无奇的人，
那你就要写你的业务结果是什么，
比如说你这次的业务的结果排名，
你不是团队的第一名，
但是呢，
你的这个业务，
同比增长了500%，
就是你可能没有拿到一个存量的结果，
但是你拿到了一个增量的结果，
然后你的增量结果比较好，
你就写增量结果，
你就说你的增量结果，
在团队里面排第一名，
你就一定要想到一个角度，
你是排第一名的，
虽然之前他跟你的KPI没有关系，
但是你就要抽离出来这个东西，
所以你的减力度会变得非常高来上，
然后你在自我介绍的时候，
对方也会对你很感兴趣，
就是中国人就是很爱竞争，
就是他一定会对你在团队里面。
拿到最好结果的这个东西感兴趣，
这个时候你就要把这件事情讲得漂亮，
讲成一个很好的故事，
面试官一定会问你说，
那你在这里面做了什么事情呢，
你就要有点像我们写不可脚本啊，
你就里面不能再单独跟他说这么一句话，
就是我做了什么什么，
然后是一个很系统，很结构性的话，
你一定要给他讲一个故事，
这个故事让你多么的印象深刻，
也让面试官记得住你，
因为我在做HR的时候，
我每天面试很多人，
我记得我当时最多的时候，
应该是七到十个人吧，
就是我一天要刚开始跟他去沟通，
就是很快，有的是电话面试，
有的是见面过来沟通，
就很快，
然后其实有很多人面试完了之后，
我记不住，
我记不起来他到底说了什么，
但是那些讲故事，讲细节的人我都记得住，
因为大家大多数讲的其实差不多，
就除非这个人之前确实他的业绩很好，
你可能对他有点印象觉得他比较优秀，
但是讲故事的那些你肯定记得住。
所以我们总结一下就是，
如果我的offer比较多的话，
那我就做一个双向筛选，
就我把自己尽可能的展现，
你适合我，我适合你，我才入职，
如果某一家公司我非常喜欢的话，
那我就从他的那个岗位需求里去提炼，
他要什么样的人，
然后我自己去进行一些匹配。
到了面试的时候，
我们要意识到，
其实HR有时候也不知道要问你什么，
所以这个时候你就需要尽可能的介绍自己，
把自己介绍到完善一点，
如果成绩比较突出，
就着重写成绩的排名，
如果成绩没有特别好讲的，
那就讲你的结果是怎么做的，
然后HR也会自动发问了，
讲的时候呢，
经常多一些细节，
多一些故事，
然后让HR记住，
这样子就是一个比较，
我们完整的求职的一个心得了。
但其实你进入社照之后，
你就会知道最重要的是，
你一定要有熟人推荐，
熟人推荐一定是高于你去海头经历的，
熟人推荐以及猎头推荐，
这两个是非常重要的，
因为你熟人推荐是会非常清楚你的嘉仪，
就是这个Leader，
他是什么样的风格，
你的这个朋友，
或者是这个熟人，
又可以直接跟你的嘉仪去做沟通，
然后说你是个什么样的风格，
所以基本上是不需要通过HR面脑，
基本上你可以直接跟嘉仪去做沟通，
我之前在自节在阿里，
内推过很多我之前的朋友，
成功率非常高，
成功率应该是在70%以上，
就甚至是之前工作经验完全不匹配的人，
但是因为我的嘉仪就是对我是熟悉的，
所以他对我推荐的人会觉得也是自己人，
所以你们就会比较轻松的进去，
但是有很多你可能在HR内观就被卡掉了，
HR其实没有那么懂业务，
他会按照通用的简历模板来去筛选，
就比如说你可能学历卡了一道，
比如说可能你之前的工作经验完全没有，
他都会给你筛掉，
但熟人推荐就可以免掉这一步，
说到这里，
我其实也可以给大家讲一个小技巧，
就是现在很多企业是以AI的招聘，
他怎么招聘呢，
就是把你的简历下载下来，
集中丢到一个Scale里，
通过Scale匹配你的简历上写的东西，
和他们的岗位需求，
比如说匹配度过了80分，
可能就进入下一轮，
所以如果你再去做一个，
你喜欢的公司的简历投地的时候，
你可以看看他们的岗位需求，
然后对你的简历做些调整，
尽量让你简历上的能力，
跟他的岗位需求做一个匹配，
你自己也可以为给AI，
问一下我这个匹配度是多少，
达到85分以上，
你再去进行投地，
就是有针对性的去修改一下简历，
并且大家其实现在也用的都是AI，
你也可以去用AI改一下，
其实你不能用同一份简历，
去投到不同的工作上面去的，
你要真想拿下来，
这个岗位一定是要针对性的，
去专门写一份简历的。
这个我还有一个小问题，
你最开始不是HR专业的吗？
到后面你到AI，
应该是去做了运营，
像这种跨了领域的一个简历的投地，
你该怎么样去应聘呢？
这个就比较有意思，
我刚好刚刚想说，
因为我之前，
我的AI上一份工作，
我是在绿地，
就是一个房地产公司，
就一是跟互联网没有关系，
二是跟我后面去的消费医疗行也没有关系，
我又做的是HR管赔生，
然后跟运营又没有关系，
所以我当时就先看了。
阿里的那个岗位JD，
我就是完全根据他的岗位JD去改的，
第一是我之前做HR的所有经理，
我都没写，
我就直接模糊掉了，
我没有写我是HR的管赔生，
我写的是我是管赔生，
所以我就写了我轮岗的经历，
这是第一条，
就是我想告诉我的应聘部门，
是我了解了一个公司的整体的运作流程，
就是我还是有一些职业化的东西在的，
我又不决现在某一个岗位上面，
写我是不管赔生，
就是我的上线，我的空间是很高的，
第二是我做的是运营，
但是我在之前的绿地，
可能我做的所有的工作跟运营。
唯一相关的一点点，
就因为我一直在做招聘嘛，
然后一直在炮笑招，
我做的跟运营相关的一点点，
就是我当时，
其实运营了绿地的公众号，
就内容运营，
我就把这块放大了，
我就是写我之前就是。
是怎么样运营这个绿地的公众号，
去跟什么样的部门去写做，
这个公众号发了多少篇，
然后相对于其他同期的公众号，
我的增长，
因为我点击，
那个点击肯定不高，
那个点击应该也就是上，
应该是一两千吧，
其实这种写出去就很丢人嘛，
但是你写他的同比增长300%，
就很牛逼嘛，
另外的话，
我写的更多的还是我的副业，
因为我一直是有个人账号的嘛，
我去面的又是消费医疗，
所以我就写我之前，
这样的账号，
然后我的粉丝体量是多少，
在这个账号上，
我之前又做过什么样的运营的动作，
就把这些，
就有点类似于把我的副业，
然后又展开，
按照这个岗位JD给写上去了，
就肯定也会写说，
我有发布多少篇的帖子，
然后在这个平台里面的搜索排名是第一，
或怎么怎么样写的，
这样的一些数据指标，
反正好一点都会马上写，
所以最后就过了简历关，
然后就进入到了面试关，
那像,
因为你在阿里自己，
像小红书你也都经历过这样的面试，
你会觉得这些不同公司，
就是像我们这种认知里的大厂，
他在这些面试的时候，
会主要看什么的，
或者说有什么风格上的不同啊，
我从阿里跳到了字节，
然后字节跳到了小红书，
中间有很大的一部分的帮助是猎头，
就猎头主动来找我，
猎头会告诉我非常多，
我不知道内部信息，
猎头会告诉我说，
我面试这个假议，
它是什么样的风格，
它具体之前，
这个团队在做什么样的业务，
就是在我面试之前，
我对这些都已经很清楚，
猎头也会根据我之前的过往经历，
告诉我说，
我现在去做的这个业务，
跟我之前做的业务有什么样的不同，
所以它会让我先了解这些东西，
就是让我自己去体链说，
我觉得这个团队跟，
我现场面的这个团队之间的不同是什么，
我要去帮忙解决的问题是什么，
我有哪些能力能解决这些问题，
所以我有点像是提前知道了考题，
我觉得大家如果是能够找猎头去做推荐，
也是很重要的，
你基本上有了工作经验三年之后，
都会有猎头主动加你，
刚刚总结就是，
如果有熟人内推，
或者说有猎头的话，
去到一个公司的成功率会更高的，
就等于说他们提前会告诉你一些信息，
因为猎头为了自己的推荐的成功率，
他也会告诉你这些的，
对，因为你能够在这个公司里面，
去成功转正过适用期，
猎头是可以拿到你的年包的抽成的，
所以他会帮你进入到这个公司，
就会给到你很多有用的信息，
还有一点是，
我觉得大家跳槽的时机很重要，
就想回答一个问题是，
我为什么能够，
就进了阿里又进了字节又进了小红书，
其实是，
时机,
对，我基本上就是面大厂，
我想面我就能过，
我这个时候已经不会去猎头了，
不会说我面好多，
因为我当时面小红书的时候，
我同时拿到了视频号的off，
就其实拿到了同讯的off，
最后选择了小红书嘛，
就当时基本上就是我想面我就能过，
除非是我觉得没有什么必要面，
因为已经有了一些塑造经验之后，
就没有必要再去猎头了，
而且这个时候不能猎头，
是因为你的猎头经历，
会在这些大公司系统上面流行，
就一定不要随便面试，
比如说你这次没准备好，
你就听说有这么一个岗位，
你就随便去面，
然后也没准备，
结果面试官给你打了一个不好的技巧，
你在他的那个招品系统上是流行的，
他会看到你之前的面评记录，
你就对于你下次再去面这个公司，
其他的岗位，
人家就是能看到你之前面试到底啥表现，
这个就很不好，
或者是你面过了，然后又没去，
你就会被拉黑，
后面就是没法再面了，
所以这个时候你肯定不能猎头，
这个时候，
我觉得是你要想清楚你想做什么，
以及你跳到了下一家公司，
你能获得什么，
然后以及你是不是真的想去这家公司很重要，
另外就是实际，
就我觉得我能从这些公司里面去跳过去，
是因为我只跳新业务，
我不跳成熟业务，
你其实能跳到成熟业务，
我觉得要不就是你是狄戏，
就是你要不就是，
你跟这个老板是认识的，
这个老板是你自己人，
他把你带过去，
然后刚好有这么一个好的坑，
把你带过去，
这个成熟的业务，
你在这边跟着他好好干，
就可以了，
其他的成熟业务，
其实你没有百分之百的把握是能跳过去的，
因为这个完全看面试观的适配风格，
只有你在面从零到一的新业务的时候，
他才会看能力，
是不是因为成熟业务，
一个萝卜一个坑，
谁来的都差不多，
所以交谁对他来说就没有太大的区别？
对，因为你在做成熟业务的时候，
其实更多的是你跟老板的信任程度，
然后你跟团队的协调能力，
你的沟通能力，
跟你个人去推动业务的这个能力，
其实不太挂钩了，
所以如果这个面试观，
就是你这个老板跟你的风格比较适配，
他想要你来这个团队，
你就可以去，
但如果你的能力很强，
然后你们的风格上还是会有很大差异的话，
就比较难，
而且成熟业务一定是没几个还抗的，
就可能你这个团队只剩这一个还抗，
然后有1000个人竞争这一个还抗，
但是新业务一定是一下子开很多还抗，
可能还是1000个人，
但是你们同事去面的是20个还抗，
那你的成功率就会高很多，
你说的学历这个点，
如果我是走社招进去的话，
会很看重学历吗？
大厂卡学历，
就是但他卡学历是卡本科，
不会说卡到就是像我们笑招嘛，
我正好想想，
我当时笑招做那个HR的时候，
我当时怎么过简历的，
就完全卡学历，
完全卡研究生，
完全国内卡985，
那个时候还是卡国内985，
然后我感觉现在的作业经验，
应该是会卡第一学历，
就第一学历可能要211或者985，
因为我们当时只卡最后一个学历，
结果很多人可能，
他的第一学历是普通本科，
然后第二学历去做了985这样子，
我们就会直接也能过，
但是现在已经卡到了第一学历，
就确实人太多了嘛，
然后坑额比较少，
那个时候我们就是国内卡985，
海外的那些留学生，
我们会卡QS100排名，
但是因为我是国内的，
我不知道QS100排名是多少，
我的公位上面是贴着QS100排名的，
所有学校的，
所以我在对简历的时候，
就是在对那个学校，
在不在这里面，
现在在社照的时候，
我看我的老板，
就是我内退的时候，
我问他要什么，
他说本科以上就可以，
这就行啊，
你肯定专科不行啊，
就是专科你的那个简历系统，
是过不了了，
本科以上就OK，
小红书这边，
我觉得也有点看，
就是看你的老板，
小红书这边，
我走之前，
我们当时也卡学历，
就算你是社照也卡，
也不能叫卡学历，
就是如果你是211985，
就加分，
就普通本科有几率，
但是211985加的分更多，
是这样吧，
对，他就会觉得，
其实要看你老板懂不懂业务，
因为我最后的公司，
老板他是其他的业务转过来，
所以他对本身的业务，
没有那么懂，
他对于其他业务跨行，
来做这件事，
他不care,
所以他更在重的是学习能力，
所以他就会卡你的学历，
那是不是学历好的，
他应聘上的成功率，
就一定会更高呢，
据你的观察，
在校照方面，
一定是百分之百是成功率更高的，
学历有点像敲门砖，
就是你的简历投地过去，
因为对于校照来说，
大家都没有工作经验，
在那个简历这些观能，
看得只有学历，
而且我们也会看长相，
因为我们每天投地的简历太多了，
你根本不知道，
我们后台的那个官网，
根本记不住，
我根本都看不完所有的简历，
我后台的官网，
每天进来都是几千缝，
我一天我都根本看不完，
我更不用说，
就是他官网过来投地都是这样，
然后更不用说有一些事，
为什么跟大家说，
一定要去宣讲会，
因为我们会优先看宣讲会的，
就官方的后台的那个，
实在太多了，
实在看不完我，
所以我们就会先看宣讲的人，
看完之后，
再去看官网后台的那些简历，
因为太多了，
然后就会卡学历，
然后卡长相。
那在社照这部分，
他过去的履历很好的话，
他也会更容易去应聘上吗？
有没有那种，
就是说他履历一直很好，
但是他就是求，
不是求的特别好的呢？
有啊,
你的沟通表达能力不好，
那肯定会在面试的时候被刷掉，
就是你的履历很好，
你的简历之外是能过的，
但是真正能不能过你的这场面试，
还是要看你跟面试官的沟通，
是不是顺畅，
但这个也有一点怎么讲的，
就是不是百分之百是。
你沟通表达的问题，
因为实话讲做很多，
LD在面你的时候，
他可能不是专心在面你，
他有自己的事情，
他可能在同时开会，
同时在面你，
所以其实你说了什么不重要，
真的不重要，
但是你的状态怎么样非常重要，
就是你说了这些他都没过脑子，
他都没有听进去，
他同时在开会，
同时在打字，
但是你的状态非常的积极，
非常的外想，
非常的有感染力，
对,
就是让他感觉到你的沟通表达非常好，
又让他感觉到你能量很强，
然后很喜欢工作，
你也很容易过，
所以我现在感觉，
求职包括面试，
更像是一场对社会的自我暴露，
就是你不仅要自我暴露，
你还要尽量暴露好的点，
你像学历，
或者说像你过去的履历，
是一个敲门砖，
等于说让你冒泡，
冒得更高，
更容易被看到，
接下来你再去沟通，
你再去表达，
你再去简历呈现上，
这个匹配程度，
也是看你的暴露的信息点，
跟他们的需求点，
匹不匹配，
包括你做一个，
比较干净的打扮，
也不是说每个人都要漂亮的，
或者说好看的，
像明星一样，
一定是帅哥美女，
但是你，
好歹把自己收拾一下，
看起来整结，
对吧，精神，
去让人记住你。
第一，一项非常重要，
对,
在在面试的时候呢，
又有比较好的沟通，
表达能力，
然后也有比较强烈的，
想要进这家公司，
或者说，
想要去工作这个欲望，
等于说，
你是在层层的暴露，
你是跟这个社会，
跟这家公司是匹配的，
它就有更大的概率，
去选中你。
对，因为我觉得，
面试其实很像 dating 约会，
就是你们见一面，
然后互相知道，
对方合不合适，
但是你们，
刚开始聊的这些东西，
又不是纯聊，
就你们每聊的一句，
其实背后都是有目的，
然后你就要再猜，
对方为什么这样发问，
他问的背后，
这个目的是什么，
这个目的又能，
去推倒出来，
这个公司，
或者这个团队，
现阶段缺的是什么，
就其实你也会，
大概有个了解，
就会知道这个公司，
这个团队，
大概是什么风格的，
现阶段，
大家又有什么样的困难点，
你也可以去选择，
说我要不要去，
解决这个困难点，
或者是我再看看别家，
所以其实求职，
就是一场人和公司的 dating，
是的,
或者是求职者，
跟面试官的，
或者是跟业务老板的 dating，
因为你们最后的相处，
也很像谈恋爱真的，
尤其是现在的环境，
我只能说，
就是如果你能跟你的老板，
搞好关系，
就跟他的相处，
变成变成是谈恋爱的，
这种方式，
你是很容易成为他自己人的，
因为我感觉现在的，
增量业务没有那么多，
所以更多的时候，
是在管理人性的，
所以你怎么样相处，
可能决定了，
你职场深雅的一个，
稳健程度吧，
对,
而且也是一个，
团队的稳定性吧，
首先,
不管是你要去面试，
还是干嘛，
先不要焦虑，
焦虑一定是，
因为你的训练不够多，
你现在觉得，
不知道怎么样去求职，
或者说，
不知道怎么样去找工作，
有一个办法，
就是先海量了，
大量的投简历，
先去通过行动，
来解决你的焦虑，
通过行动，
来得到一个更好的，
能力锻炼，
对,
而且你一定要先去投，
一些你不想去的公司，
因为刚开始，
你能成功的，
机率真的蛮低的，
就包括，
是我在孝昭的时候，
我刚开始投的那些公司，
其实也，
很多都是没有过第一轮的，
第二个就是，
在简历的制作过程中，
可能过了他们的，
那个敲门砖，
比如说，
你的第一学历，
过了他们敲门砖之后，
你就要尽量的，
去表现你的，
比如说，
扛压能力，
沟通表达能力，
可以有意识的，
去训练出来的，
就像我跟肉环路波克，
我们也会在反思，
我们是不是有哪些地方，
没有沟通好，
然后我们，
会专门的，
就拉一些十几分钟，
二十分钟的会，
我们来想，
怎么样去沟通的更顺畅，
就比如今天，
这个波克，
我们就是在前天，
花了二十多分钟，
去做了一次沟通，
我觉得我们的表达，
都是有提升的，
对,
而且我们，
会提前把，
框架都打好，
所以这个东西，
它也是可以，
通过刻意训练，
对,
而且我觉得，
大家去面试的时候，
一定要搞清楚，
它为什么要招人，
就是其实，
起业招人，
一定是为了产生更多的价值，
所以,
当你,
尤其是谈心的时候，
你必须要，
要去扛產出的
怎麼把它說人話呢？
就比如說
你現在就算是一個中臺的團隊。
你就算是一個非業務團隊。
比如說你這個團隊是純做營銷的。
然後你本身是不可能直接產出GMV的。
這樣的團隊
你也是要綁定這樣的GMV目標。
然後來計算你整個團隊。
能賺多少利潤
團隊的工資是多少。
如果是你的整個的利潤打不平的話。
是一定會財源的
很多時候我把數據給到老闆。
或者說給到誰去看。
不能說是為了讓老闆知道。
這個數據我來了之後。
他有多大的轉變
或者說跟我多少的相關性。
而是為了證明這個數據跟我沒有關係。
有很多時候你的那些數據證明。
其實是為了證明自己沒鍋。
這個事情
我覺得大家要逐漸學會去接受它。
我覺得還有一個點是。
因為你的文字體系。
大家溝通起來很困難。
就每個人都有自己的文字體系。
但是數據
所有人都是通用的。
數據不會騙人
對 你用數據指標去跟他人溝通的時候。
一定不會出現溝通流失的東西。
所以這樣子
大家都會更加清晰明瞭。
你到底在做什麼
然後你的能力指標是在哪個位置。
就這樣會更容易對齊。
所以我們這期播客的發布時間。
應該也是很多
大三的學生
可能馬上要進入大四。
以及大四的學生
一個畢業的節點
也就是說大三的同學。
可能要迎來一個笑招。
那你現在其實就可以開始行動起來了。
先去找大量
你沒有意象的企業。
先去練手
然後做一些刻意的訓練。
後面再以更多的行動。
去解決你的交流
這樣子你的成功率可能會更高。
如果大三是笑招的話。
就是一定要做好信息篩選。
因為我當時是有去列日程表的。
所以我一天要去的地方太多了。
所以我會先列出這段時間。
過來做選講的
企業有哪些
然後以及我在線上。
能觸達到這些官網的企業。
有哪一些
後續可能是通過一些。
第三方的那種工作號。
或者是第三方的一些平台。
他們會給到的一些笑招的。
就頭地的這些官網是哪一些。
我就會列這種一個大的表。
去頭了我就打勾
然後進了下一輪
就會往後去排
所以我覺得大家可以先清晰一下。
就是你到底要去投哪一些簡歷。
包括你最想做的那幾家。
你可以標註
然後變成你的目標企業。
然後你會在他們要來的。
這個合適的時間
提前先
比如說練武家
練使家
就會比較有信心
在他們這邊面試
如果是社招的話
是不是可以找你內推。
可以
這是如果是想走互聯網的話。
基本上
因為我生命的統治。
大家分佈在不同的互聯網平台。
那我們是可以去做內推的。
大家如果有想獲得內推名額。
或者說想跟我們交流。
更多的關於招聘求職的經驗的朋友。
也可以加我們的聯繫方式。
進到我們的聽眾群裡。
然後我們再來根據簡歷。
給大家做一個內推。
對
就是如果大家想要在互聯網。
這個行業去投資簡歷的話。
就可以進入到我們的聽眾群。
到時候我們可以給大家去發一些內推。
為什麼你沒有給我內推。
因為你已經超過35歲了。
我認識福
好吧？
那我們今天這期就先錄到這裡。
大家有什麼問題
也可以在評論區跟我們留言討論。
也可以私信我們
或者說加我們的好友。
然後到我們的聽眾群裡一起討論。
好的
那我們本期播客就到這裡結束了。
拜拜